but just back to the question who has
more power and influence
well I would say that they're all one I
guess it's the short answer nice yeah no
they're they're all kind of one you're
absolutely right yeah you're absolutely
right that's something I've been saying
for for years now and a lot of people
don't understand that there really isn't
much of a difference when it comes to
the decisions the major ones that they
make well now we're getting uh evidence
in these these lawsuits that the the
federal government was instructing
directing big Tech to censor people they
didn't like right yeah right and it's
been a Cascade we've gotten a little bit
here and now it's now it's full swing
now we've got emails where I think Alex
Berenson is that's the name that's a
journalist right yeah where they're like
why hasn't he been banned yet Twitter
and then Twitter's like okay and then he
gets banned Dr couch Dr fauci parody
accounts got hit because the White House
did something for them too that is
absolutely crazy